[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is our first aveer John and Hank it's
a comedy podcast about death and also
other stuff in which two brothers Hank
and John Green will give you dubious
advice bring you all the week's news for
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon answer your
questions and I forgot you can yes
advice how you doing John I'm all right
I'm proofreading right now or I'm like
dealing with the proofreaders queries
for Turtles all the way down my new book
coming out October 10th available for
pre-order now it probably signed Turtles
calm so when people when you have it
when you when there's something spelled
wrong in your book they're like hey did
you want to keep this spelled wrong or
do you want to have it be spelled right
now that is one of the issues but it's
also like should you capitalize the T in
FaceTime is thank you then there's no
big there's the big difficult questions
like you know word choice questions
between what is technically the correct
word and the word that everyone says
like which is better to pick in that
situation and it really proofreading
gets down to like those parts of grammar
where you're forced to think about why
grammar exists which is sort of
interesting but also I've only had like
three hours of sleep so it's a little
exhausting right now how are you good
John do you know about 80 percentage no
what is 80 percent in eighty percent
thing is the idea that the first 80
percent of the work is actually only
twenty percent of the work and the last
20 percent is like 80 percent of the
work so getting 80% of the way there is
20 percent and then the getting the last
20 percent is like 80 percent of the
work and so what you should do is just
forget about that last 20 percent and
say hey look if there's a bunch of words
spelled wrong in this book that's cuz I
only wanted to get 80% of the way there
I had other stuff to do I had to sleep I
have children I have a podcast with my
brother Hank I have to be sharp and I
have to be good and funny and I'm not
gonna worry about whether FaceTime has a
capital T well I'll tell you what Hank
eighty percent ninety nine percent of my
professional life I eighty percent every
vlogbrothers video for the last eight
years so just let me have this one thing
that I spend a lot of time on I should
just make a video on 80 percent Inge and
it should it should just end like 80
percent of the way through just stop
no no no I'll see you on Tuesday just
yeah that's a it's it's conceptually
strong I don't know if I would actually
enjoy watching it though
Oh John 101 episodes how are you feeling
oh great couldn't be happier just a
little bit tired due to the lack of the
sleeping I think that I'm not gonna I
will get some sleep once this book goes
into production in mid-august but until
then I'm just gonna be I'm just gonna be
the little engine that could Hank would
you like a short poem for today hey yes
I would
alright this uh this short poem is from
Emily Bronte but it was published under
her gnome de plume Ellis Bell and also
I'm not going to read the whole thing it
was sent to me by a listener named
Sylvia who suggested it because we
always talk about that Emily Dickinson
poem with hope is the thing with
feathers and and she wanted me to read
this poem because it's much more
negative about hope but I'm only going
to read the final stanza hope whose
whisper would have given balm to all my
friends II to pain stretched her wings
and soared to heaven went and never
returned again hope by Emily brontë a
story about hope leaving and never
returning hope is the thing with
feathers it flies away from you and does
not come back that's right
alright John we've got a first question
it's from Ben who asks dear Hank and
mainly John where would i preorder a
paperback version of your book turtles
all the way down that's coming out my
girlfriend and I both greatly dislike
hardcover books I like turtles
Ben alright I'm DS for Ben yeah I have
bad news for Ben but then I also have
more bad news for Ben the first piece of
bad news is that my book Turtles all the
way down
is not very deeply concerned with
turtles it's like turtle free it's like
like like how many like how many turtles
are in the book John is it like just
like a Lok no turtle book I would say
it's not a no turtle book but it's
definitely a lo turtle book sort of
looking for a high turtle book I
actually have a recommendation yeah yeah
which is rare but I do I have a good
recommendation of a turtle heavy book
it's called the people in the trees and
it's by hanya yanagihara and it's very
good so if you're looking for a turtle
book check that one out however if
you're looking to read my new book in
paperback
I would advise patience so the reason
books come out in hardcover before they
come out in paperback is there's a bunch
of reasons but the main one is that
hardcover books are more expensive and
the royalties are better much much much
better for authors
so authors are usually in favor of hard
covers coming up before paperbacks one
thing that you could do though is you
could rip off the hardcover and then
just go all the pages together and then
put on your own softcover and that might
suit your interests better but also I
think hardcover books are beautiful and
this book will be very beautiful I have
seen some of the like comps for what its
gonna look like
have you seen a cover I have seen a
cover but I've also seen all the all the
little detailed stuff that I really love
in books the way they bind the books the
quality of the paper all that stuff is
really good like it's it's finally as -
in terms of a physical item it's finally
the my like all of my dreams coming true
so I'm sorry Ben but I also think that
you're gonna like the physical book
available for pre-order now at probably
signed Turtles com
I like the idea of just getting you
exacto knife out and being like hurry
wrap that those things are gone it's
about personal preference yeah yeah I
won't be mad I mean the book belongs to
you so do what you want with it but the
paperback will eventually come out and
I'm sorry that it's going to take a
while but I have worked very hard and
fought to make sure that the hardcover
is relatively inexpensive in fact
cheaper than lots of paperback novels
coming out these days this
comes from Maya who writes dear green
brothers what would be the ecological
effects if all mosquitoes died if there
was a virus or something that eradicated
all mosquitoes when ecosystems go to
chaos or would we get along fine I'm
asking because mosquitoes are the
devil's spawn and also may spread
diseases that kill a lot of people
thanks for asking Valar morghulis but
mosquitoes first my nice mosquitoes yeah
all men must die but mostly I mean
mosquito by men I mean I mean mosquitoes
I yeah you know first of all it's not we
don't have to kill all mosquitoes there
are so many species of mosquitoes that
aren't the ones that bug us that much
and and there are only a few species of
mosquitoes that transmit malaria and
which is the biggest mosquito problem
and then and so you you really only have
to like hit a couple of species for it
to be a really big difference but I
think for the most part we'd be okay
like there's stuff that eats mosquitoes
but those things eat other things too I
like this idea that like that all like
the entire ecosystem is in balance and
it like everything has its place like
ticks
no no just they should all die they
don't do anything useful that is spread
disease and suck blood like that like
they work they function eka ecologically
they do it just fine job but no yeah we
could we could probably we can
definitely get rid of the mosquitoes
that are the worst offenders without any
problems in fact we have tried and we
continue to try and we have succeeded in
some places yeah I mean there used to be
a lot of malaria in North America and
now there's none so there there has been
a lot of progress but we have a long
long way to go there is actually an
article in Nature about this Hank and it
has a great I won't read you the whole
article because like most articles in
nature it's a bit of a difficult read
but it has a great sub-headline
eradicating any organism would have
serious consequences for ecosystems
wouldn't it not when it comes to
mosquitoes that's all you really need we
did a scishow on it too if you want to
watch that it's probably a little more
penetrable than the nature article ok if
we have another question and this one is
one of those big difficult questions it
comes from Ashley
dear brothers green I was babysitting
for a family I don't know very well and
the baby took his first step I was there
that's guilt should I tell the parents
Ashley oh man no definitely don't do
that what yeah
no because you because like that
everybody's always like I don't know I I
want to be there when Oren takes his
first steps and I might not be in like
I'll be bummed if I'm not so like just
like who gets hurt by that lie of
omission you don't have to be like well
hey guys your baby definitely didn't
empty take any steps while you were gone
not a walker that one see I would argue
that if anything you should lie in the
other direction you should be like
listen not only did your baby take his
first steps he also said his first word
and it was Ashley it was my name he
looked me dead in the eyes and he said
hello Ashley I love you more than I love
my mother and that was all he said it
was weird and then he was like and then
he said I know they're only paying you
$20 an hour and that's crap
don't accept it I've worth so much more
than that
that's what he said that's all that's
all and then he stopped he clammed up
and he hasn't said anything since so I
don't know that's just take it take take
what you will from that walked all the
way across the room told me he did not
approve of my compensation package and
then clamp right back up anyway really a
pleasure to babysit for your
astonishingly verbal extremely mobile
child yeah I'll see you next time is it
is it possible that I could that I could
get us some equity in this bay because I
put a lot in
just uh just a low percentage I don't
know how does it work it's not is that
how you think maybes working that like
you currently own 100% of Oren's future
earnings I don't on one other percent of
Lauren's future earnings but I
definitely untitled I'm entitled to a
percentage okay I look forward to the
conversation that you have with Oren
when he enters the workforce no no it's
not initial compensation it's only after
I'm old and in the home when I expect
affect him to contribute to the keep
keep dad in in diapers and and you know
Scientific American subscriptions wait
think our parents are expecting that do
you
you know I think I think it I think it's
gonna depend I nominate you as I do so
often all right I just just to be clear
though Ashley no no no no no you should
not tell the parents that you saw the
baby take his first steps okay John
John's come around and he's decided to
unless you are directly asked yet and
then I guess maybe you have to say yes
but even then probably not yeah
John has abandoned the bit and he and he
wants to make sure that you don't
actually tell them this question comes
from Bree who asks dear Hank and John I
recently started dating someone and
everything's great he's super sweet he
makes me laugh and have a great time
when I'm with him but I recently found
out that he is a not so tiny following
online he's somewhat of a popular
YouTube person and he has a decent
amount of Twitter followers enough to
where people notice and stop him when
we're out and they want pictures I never
wanted a life in the public eye and with
the growing maliciousness of the YouTube
community I'm not sure that I could
handle it how do I to handle this
budding relationship while also handling
keeping myself out of the public eye if
that is even possible completely lacking
a sign-off Bree
oh my so surprised YouTube celebrity
boyfriend yeah I mean I feel like that's
a great question for our spouses because
yeah unexpectedly developed to surprise
YouTube husbands well into the
relationship yeah but at least with that
there was a measure of I don't know
there was a little bit of Buy in like
Sarah was in favor of Brotherhood 2.0 as
a concept
sure yeah it was like and it happened
somewhat gradually it wasn't like and
surprised that there were lots of
decisions along the way that yeah that
were that they were involved in that
said it's hard yeah it's hard yeah I
mean it's it's it's also weird because I
don't like I don't think that you know
traditional celebrity is the same ness
thoroughly and so like it's you're kind
of an unmapped
territory here so I don't know that
anyone has particularly good advice for
you except for people who have been in
this exact position before but I will
say that that you know it when you talk
about the maliciousness of the YouTube
community it isn't necessarily in that
person's part of the community there are
a lot of areas of YouTube that are that
are like just kind and supportive and
maybe are smaller but are big enough
that people will still get recognized at
the grocery store or whatever and that
is it the way that that Fame has changed
where you know 99% of people have no
idea who your boyfriend is probably but
1% is a lot like you see more than a
hundred people if you go to the grocery
store maybe not but at some grocery
stores I feel like I do that place just
is full of people and yeah so it might
macum down to the individual like the
situation but but also like that's a
pretty it's not a cool thing like is
that also kind of dope like is there
also like opportunities that like meat
things will happen that you wouldn't
otherwise have happened where you get to
have experiences and do things yeah I
don't know I I think it depends on the
person but I do think you have to be
realistic that you are yeah at least
until the moment when that when the
person you're dating starts talking
about you online I think you're
relatively anonymous after that you know
there is an element of not being fully
anonymous and to be honest this is
something in a way Hank and I have never
been through the worst parts of because
we've never had like a public break up
which is where I think it's really hard
and where you do see some viciousness at
times even in very supportive
communities so I totally get the concern
but I also think until and unless you're
explicitly mentioned I think you can
kind of fly under the radar yeah there
are certain kinds of YouTube content
that that like ask for all that person's
life to be laid out in front of everyone
and and if you were in a relationship
with one of those people you would know
it like you would know from the
beginning because the camera would be
out all the time but
people just like make videos that are
about a certain thing and they aren't
about their life and and so you don't
necessarily have to be a part of their
like public narrative right right
speaking of public narratives Hank I
want to answer this question it comes
from Rebecca who writes dear John and
Hank I loved your podcast and it
enriches my life Rebecca that is far too
kind literally it is too kind about yeah
are completely suboptimal podcast I'm
quite the Beatles fan and the other day
when I was listening to John Lennon's
Imagine my brother joined me and said
that it was a wonderful song but he
didn't like the political message it was
sending and something about communism my
question is what political message does
imagine send out and also can I continue
enjoying it once I know the truth behind
it
thankful for any advice Rebecca well so
there's key questions here I also I yeah
I want everybody to keep on the lookout
for my new YouTube video the truth about
John Lennon's Imagine God God that is
such a genre of YouTube videos there's
two questions here one is can you enjoy
art that you find politically
reprehensible and the other question is
is John Lennon's Imagine a communist
song and if so is that so bad yeah no I
mean first of all even like I don't know
that you can find the well I feel like
that yeah I can I can definitely not
enjoy content because of the message it
sends yeah yes but you also III also
think that like sometimes you can enjoy
content despite the passage it sends
like I can I can like a song even if
there are things in it that I find
objectionable sure um the answer to is
imagine a communist song is yeah yeah
imagine no possessions I wonder if you
can no greed no need for greed or hunger
a brotherhood of man that's pretty
yeah that's pretty Lenin II that's got
so it's got a glen ernie vibe nothing to
kill or die for that's not less grana
knee
there's lots of things to kill the die
for if you're communist Russia but they
do say no religion - yeah which is
pretty that was like that feels whenever
you know whenever I hear that song I
like think about in the 60s saying like
imagine no religion like whoa hold on
there bucko that's a that's a danger
time that you've entered but yeah people
you know people heard that and I think
part of the message of imagine and
what's nice about this song is that it
isn't saying like hey there shouldn't be
really a religion there shouldn't be
possessions it's just saying let's
question this let's look at it for a
second and see what like where the thing
is valuable and where it isn't and
without saying like you know without
without questioning it then you don't
ever get a chance to really even
appreciate the good things that might
come from things so but in the end he
does say you may say that I'm a dreamer
but I'm not the only one I hope someday
you'll join us in kind of saying all of
these things I have asked you to imagine
are things that I want to happen but
yeah I mean it's pretty commie song but
that doesn't mean it's not beautiful
well also it also doesn't mean that it's
wrong right yeah I you know I I don't
know I don't I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
get into ideology here I do want to
point out though that Hank is completely
correct about the the difference about
saying imagine no religion in nineteen
I'm gonna guess like 72 or 73 when I'm
gonna guess that song came out versus
today which is that then the vast
majority of people in the United States
at least did go to church every week and
now it is a fewer than 40 percent and
well under 40 percent so yeah yeah 795
change 1971 John good good job thank you
that well I know when the beatles broke
up and unfortunately I know when John
Lennon was assassinated so I knew it was
somewhere in there um let's uh move on
to another question Hank this is another
one I really wanted to answer today all
right it comes from Peter who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a teenaged boy
who is a longtime fan of the pod and I
have a
I'm very interested in knitting however
I am scared that if I try to learn how
to knit I will be judged as a wuss
or a [ __ ] how do I solve this problem
the jaws of death will engulf you Peter
well Peter you've already got the
sign-off thing figured out and that's
great yeah I don't think that there's
nothing you could do here if you're
interested in a thing and you're worried
about what people are gonna think about
you you either don't do the thing
because that the the fear is too great
or you do it and you deal with it and
you look at those people and you think
why are you so silly this is like what
about this particular activity which by
the way involves giant like basicly
weapons that sometimes TSA won't even
let you bring on plane how is this a pro
is this in particular what happened in
society that this is a thing that is
supposed to be feminine when like
clearly it has no gender right yeah I
mean but it is it it is also hard when
you are a teenager to to stand up to
gender constructions and to stand up to
those messages that tell you that you're
going to be less of a person worth
valuing if you do this or do that that
said it is awesome it is courageous and
it makes the world better and it makes
your life better in the long run so I I
encourage you to knit knit like a mofo
just chars are that mofo to go all the
way back to the beginning of this
podcast I hope I hope you find it man I
hope you find the will to knit I think
that was awesome
and I think you also got to recognize
that what's gonna happen to you is what
happens to 95% of knitters is like you
figure it out and you start doing it and
then it's like oh yeah okay I get it
I don't really need to make sweaters for
the rest of my life I don't know
actually you might not find that you
might find that it's super fun and
challenging and interesting and that
sweaters that's what happens that's what
happens to most people just having
watched my my friends go through their
knitting craze but also that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's not going to
come back
you have a skill that's always there
ready for you to apply it you know
especially post-apocalypse like making
making like useful things out of strings
is definitely a good thing to be able to
do grace point here yeah great point
that reminds me in fact that today's
podcast is brought to you by knitting
knitting an amazing post-apocalyptic
Talent no so good this podcast is also
brought to you by turtle books books
about turtles their books with
high quantities of turtles have a
recommended daily value completely
satisfied one hundred and fifty percent
of turtles but that which is not John's
book turtles all the way down today's
podcast has also brought to you by
nothing to kill or die for with men be
nice wouldn't that be nice and and
finally this podcast is brought to you
by hey John
yes audible Oh audible the amazing thing
where I listened to all of my audiobooks
from that's that is correct you know
John I figure we've got to start out and
start out podcast sponsorship so we
should really just do the ones that
every everybody like it's not like you
haven't heard about audible right here
here's my thing that I think people will
probably wonder why do does audible
continue to sponsor so many podcasts
when I obviously already know about
audible right two reasons one cuz it's
really great and helps podcasters make a
living too because maybe you're the
person who's just been on the fence and
you've heard about audible but you
haven't quite signed up yet and they're
trying to they're trying to get that
person who hasn't so if you're thinking
about it now maybe the chance to try and
go and look and see if you want to get
your free book your free download that
you can get with our link instead of any
other podcasts link and John we have a
link as you know and there are two
because there are always two because you
get to choose whether you want to use to
your Hank or Dear John at audible.com
slash D or Hank or audible.com slash
Dear John I'm not gonna try to bias you
one way or another although I will point
out that audible.com slash Dear John
allows you to just use the right side of
your keyboard on that Jo HN so
that's better but it's up to you point
being you can get a free audiobook right
now at audible.com slash Dear John and
it could be The Fault in Our Stars which
was read by Kate Rudd one of my favorite
audiobook narrators she's amazingly
talented she has lots and lots of books
on audible but The Fault in Our Stars is
one of them
you can also get Paper Towns or Looking
for Alaska or any of my books on audible
or you can get something that Hank would
like like I don't know are you listened
to anything on Auto Mall right now John
I'm listening
to Jane Austen's persuasion oh yeah
that's available it's good I'm listening
right now to the second book in the
expanse series a caliban's war by James
sa Corey which is so good the book the
first one is also very good and I love I
love like I when I'm listening to a
series of books I love like sticking
like that it sticks with the same
narrator and I get this feeling that
like the Harry Bosch series by Michael
Connelly is like that where he is so I
get so connected with the narrator and
his voice for telling the story I also I
love that and and yeah the expanse
series is fantastic the show is great
and and the books are great and there's
way more of the books than there is of
the show so you can be in the world
longer which is exciting for me and I
just finished The Immortal Life of
Henrietta Lacks which also was
fantastically read and and very super
frickin interesting everybody I've been
told over and over and over again that I
need to read this book and I kind of
sometimes have a hard time reading
nonfiction on paper but this was like
such a good cohesive story that kept
driving through it and like kept me
wanting to listen to the next chapter
that I was really glad I listened to it
as an audiobook yeah I I loved that book
I read it you know with with words but
I'm sure the audiobook was good so again
that's audible.com slash dear Hank or
audible.com slash Dear John my personal
favorite where you can get a free
audiobook and a 30-day trial of audible
it really is a cool service and we thank
them for sponsoring today's podcast yeah
they've got like the crazy thing like I
didn't even know this I was like using
audible one day like on the toilet and
it like I went over and I
suddenly realize that there's a bunch of
content that isn't books that's
available like articles from major news
sources and like audible specific
content from like ashley ford has a
podcast where she interviews authors
it's just great stuff yeah yeah
Ashley Ford of course hosted one of the
episodes of dear Hank and John when Hank
was out on paternity leave so yeah she's
great and you can listen to her podcast
at audible.com slash Dear John okay
let's go back to answering questions
Hank this question comes from Alison who
writes dear John and Hank I'm moving out
of my parents house bachelor degree in
hand to a new state Birmingham Alabama
actually you may know a thing or two
about that place Hank was born there I
lived there for a long time in the
process of coming into my own and
venturing out into this grown-up world
I've discovered that furniture is heck
and expensive hundreds of dollars for a
chair I've also realized that I'm vastly
unprepared for this I don't know how
taxes work I don't know how to set up
Wi-Fi at my house I'm curious what were
some of the things that you were
blindsided by slash not expecting when
you became real adults also if you have
advice about moving to a new state I'm
all ears
later Vader Allison I got say the cost
of furniture continues to shock me oh
man I remember when I bought my first
couch with Sarah because before that I'd
only ever purchased couches at garage
sales and stuff yeah yeah and I when we
moved to New York we bought a couch and
I was in Jennifer convertibles to buy
this couch and first off I was like
Sarah why are we at this fancy furniture
store and she was like this is literally
the cheapest furniture store that I
would ever enter and then secondly I was
like can someone explain to me why this
couch is $900 like I still think like
$900 like what what does it do does it
turn into a bed yes as it happens it did
but still doesn't turn into a car yeah I
think it's rather a car for $900 cars
have like one couch and two chairs
inside of them and you can sometimes
find a used one that runs for just over
$900 so really it is insane Alex
Furniture is on the other hand a lot of
work goes into making them etc etc yeah
try to move around but but what I will
say is like like what sometimes you
don't realize is like living in your
parents house
it took them decades to collect all the
furniture they have they didn't start
out and like buy it all at once they
probably had not so much furniture at
all and probably you know had a bunch
that they've got at thrift stores or
garage sales and then slowly got rid of
the crappy things and replaced them with
good things and and it's important to
know that you like not only can't you
but you should not suddenly go into
twenty thousand dollars of credit card
debt furnishing a home and yeah what
else Hank I just want to interrupt you
real quickly and say that you implied
that the stuff that you get at garage
sales isn't good and I would like to
save that I still have one of my garage
sale couches and it remains in some ways
it is certainly not our most physically
attractive caption but I would argue it
is our most comfortable couch yeah rugs
are also something that that really
shocked me and it's like this is a thing
that I step on I just walk on this all
day long why is this why is this so
expensive why am I going to require so
much work to create that's yeah yeah
yeah it makes it makes sense but yeah
I'm like well no rugs for me for a while
and setting up Wi-Fi you can do it
paying taxes you can do it but it's
harder than setting up Wi-Fi I don't
know they're both very hard okay I mean
I remember I have a vivid memory of like
setting up we didn't have Wi-Fi back
then have I ever told this story about
when yes you have my roommate came home
with Wi-Fi yeah are you sure I hope you
have on the pyre yes are you totally
positive I'm like I'm like 98% sure I'm
gonna tell it again so my roommate
Shannon came home with a computer with
Wi-Fi and she was like look no cords no
cables and anywhere within 50 feet of
this machine that I bought that was a
wireless router I can get access to the
Internet and I said joke's on you
because I have a 100 foot ethernet cord
oh I'm glad that you laughed at my joke
despite having heard it literally $4,000
not the third it's at least not the
third anyway
the joke's on Shannon because I figured
out that Wireless was a complete scam if
you just owned a 100 foot ethernet cord
and to this day I refuse to get
computers with wireless just kidding I
was clearly wrong about that so it is a
pain to like set up all of that stuff
but you also have to remember Allison
that you're setting stuff up and then
once it's set up it works well until it
stops working I what I want Allison to
know is that like you you gotta figure
stuff out that's that's that's what
that's what adulthood is it's like I
don't know how to do this and it's like
oh okay well I'll just do it I will say
do not do not put washing like washing
machine like clothes washing stuff into
the dishwasher that's a bad idea what
yeah or the other way around don't do it
either way the dishwasher has the it
stuff and the the clothes washer has it
stuff and they are not the same they are
not the same and do not put hot oil into
a milk jug is another thing to not do
that's a good one I'll I'll give you one
that I learned the hard way when I was
23 sometimes you want to eat frozen
pizza and you put it in the micro four
hundred fifty degrees for 18 minutes and
then about like four minutes after you
start cooking the pizza you want to go
bowling and so you go bowling and you a
bit of an obsessive bowler so you Bowl
by yourself for three and a half hours
when you come home first off you're
gonna be so happy that the whole house
didn't burn down but secondly you're
gonna have some really annoyed roommates
oh my goodness oh my god it's burning it
actually was the burning Jon it was
happened to you yeah that's that thing
not a great decision by me I would shout
out to all the people who are cooking
while they listen to dear Hank and John
make sure that you set your timer and
that it's
enough to get through your earbuds
alright I got one last question for you
John says dear brothers from RJ do power
plants produce their own electricity how
is a power plant turned on if it
produces its own power do other power
plants pay to use electricity do power
plants have to pay to use electricity
these are the questions I need answer to
I have no use for these answers RJ I
need answers to these questions by which
I mean I don't need answers to these
questions well Hank I think I think of
power plants just like any other
building like the the power goes out of
the power plant it goes to the place
where all the power goes and gets
shifted around and and joins up on the
grid and then it comes back so yeah like
if you turn off the like you got to make
it so that if you turn off the power
plant it still has power somehow you
don't like all the computers and TV TVs
because they're watching sports I guess
and lights to turn off just because the
power plant needs maintenance so you're
you're on the grid like don't like
anybody else and yeah you got to pay for
power even if you're a power plant even
if you're throwing it off like more than
you could ever possibly use you just tap
into the grid like anybody else no
that's that's interesting I'm glad I
learned that Hank before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want
to read one quick correction that came
in from Elliot who had a bunch of issues
with the way we talked about how we know
climate change is real in that in that
discussion Hank we both said that you
have to rely on experts and the only way
to know as much as a climate scientist
does about climate is to be a climate
scientist Elliot broadly agreed with
this but he also pointed out that the
nature of science is for it to be open
and available for people to explore and
to question and to use the scientific
method to come to better understandings
which i think is an important point and
also he said that it is actually not
that complicated to prove to people that
we know that humans are causing the
earth to get hotter so I'm just gonna
read his explanation because I thought
it was good people put tons of effort
into measuring humanity's greenhouse
emissions and it lines up reasonably
well with similarly large efforts to
measure atmospheric carbon worldwide
here's a NASA visualization which
we will put on the patreon it's a pretty
straightforward pretty straightforward
physical models say that this will cause
climate change so it's hard to see how
it wouldn't affect global temperatures
and importantly those human emissions
are literally the only known factor that
remotely explains the rising
temperatures that we see hmm
so there you go Hank yes John did
anything happen on a cold dead Rock
millions of miles from Earth yesterday
no but yes many things happened on on
Mars yesterday and other cold dead rocks
as well had had things happen to them
but the thing the thing that I'm gonna
talk about is not did not actually
happen on Mars it happened here on earth
so John you know that they're working on
a they're working on a new launch system
to get heavier bigger stuff farther and
faster than ever before and so we've got
this engine that's gonna take us
hopefully if if all if all works out as
planned and and you know we don't need
to start knitting our own shirts to Mars
there's in this engine you may have
heard of it John it's called the rs.25
and when I say you've heard of it you
have oblique all that but it's just the
same engine that they used on the space
shuttle
they had three of them on the the main
engine of the space shuttle and it burns
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen to
create water and it throws off a
tremendous amount of hot gas and that
exits very quickly from the nozzle 13
times the speed of sound so if it kept
going that fast it would go from Los
Angeles to New York in about 15 minutes
luckily it doesn't or it well that would
be a problem but it basically it's a
huge engine it's about the size of like
a like a Honda Fit and it has these four
extremely fast turbo pumps and it's a
reliable thing we've never had
significant problems with them and we
know how they work really well because
we use them for a long time on the space
shuttle and instead of having three of
them the Space Launch System will have
four of them and they've actually
changed the controller a little bit the
kind of brain that
operates how how the engine works how
much gas is going through it and how the
valves and pumps and things are going
change that a little bit so that it
actually produces about 10% more thrust
than they did when they were used in the
space shuttle and we were doing our
first tests of of that new control
system for the SLS or maybe not our
first but they're doing they're testing
it right now actively testing the the
rs.25 engine and if you want to watch a
video with that I'll throw that one up
on the patreon as well because man is it
impressive they put it in this building
I just love it they like put it in this
building and then the building has to be
anchored into the ground super-hard is
usually the problem you have is that it
like you don't want a building to like
like you're fighting against gravity but
this building has to fight against this
engine that's trying to lift it into
space so they have this giant engine
that has to channel the the gases as
it's exiting the engine out but it's
just very impressive and it runs for a
very long time like about eight minutes
which does not seem like a long time
until it is a giant engine that produces
just massive massive amounts of thrust
so working on that and in doing testing
of it right now wow that sounds pretty
exciting actually cool thing yeah yeah
rocket science John well the news from
AFC Wimbledon is not rocket science as
they say in fact just moments ago AFC
Wimbledon wrapped up one of their final
friendlies before the soccer season
officially starts against Scunthorpe on
August 5th so it is the end of our long
international nightmare Hank
finally at last we are returning to
regular soccer however just played
Aldershot Town in a pre-season friendly
Aldershot Town currently playing in the
fifth tier of English soccer so not in
the football league not in the not a
team in the Football League yep however
we did not lose to them we also did not
beat them it was a 1:1 hoorah and our
new goalkeeper MacDonald had a
a good game which on the upside means
that he might be very good on the
downside that means that there were a
lot of chances for Aldershot Town so he
made some very good good saves and mmm
that is the news I just we just have to
hope that the preseason has been mixed
results I would say and I think we have
to have the ambition and the hope that
the betting markets are right so the
betting markets Hank have AFC Wimbledon
finishing 17th ish and that would that
would suit my interest just fine because
I love sponsoring a third tier English
soccer team and it is my ambition to
continue sponsoring one until one day
they have a brand new stadium and maybe
with with some luck and some investment
can become a second tier English soccer
team I mean that that I mean John don't
you want them to be a first-year English
soccer team though I do that would be
great and certainly all things are
possible but there would have to be some
kind of collapse in the British economy
that I don't want to root for because
right now that for all the Premier
League teams can spend like an actual
hundred million dollars every summer so
it seems pretty far away for AFC one
will then to be spending that kind of
money but life is full of surprises and
certainly who could have guessed that
they would be promoted six times in
their since being reborn so anything is
possible
I'm gonna keep my fingers crossed but in
the meantime we're not losing to
Aldershot Town which is also something I
mean could you since since they did so
well could you like recruit a couple
Aldershot Town players may be out of the
question
some players I was watching Jamaica play
the United States at the Gold Cup and
the Jamaican keeper was unfortunately
injured and so they had to bring in
their backup keeper it was a 30 year old
playing in the second tier of Sweden and
I was watching this second tier Swedish
goalkeeper and he was making some really
good saves and I did think you know I
have knee lard Lee's phone number I
could get I got yeah cuz cuz I'm sure
nobody else is watching that game
yeah well actually it is possible that I
was the only person watching that game
yeah I don't know I have no idea
Hank what did we learned it Oh John we
learned that cars have like a couch and
two chairs in them so why do I have to
pay so much for couches and chairs we
also learned that lying to your
babysitting clients is sometimes the
right thing to do absolutely a hundred
percent and we learned that you got it
you got to kill all those mosquitos so
if you see a mosquito kill a mosquito do
not worry about the ecological
consequences and maybe if we all just
work together we can get them all which
we definitely can't yeah I was gonna say
I don't mmm I mean if we work together
like as a species increase you know
dramatically increased funding for anti
malarial efforts maybe but I think just
by smashing them one at a time probably
not and lastly we learned that Turtles
all the way down does not have that many
actual turtles in it it is a low turtle
book job Oh mostly a metaphor hey thanks
John for podcasting with me thanks
people it's my pleasure who listened and
sent in questions if you would like to
send in questions you could do that at
Hank and John at gmail.com John you're
on Twitter sometimes editor comm slash
John Green I'm on Twitter at twitter.com
slash Hank green if you liked audible
and are thinking maybe I am gonna get
into this audiobook game maybe I maybe I
do want to check this out this is a free
free trial ted's it's a month long and
you can go to audible.com slash dear
Hank or Dear John dear Hank and John is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
Sheridan Gibson our editor is Nicholas
Jenkins Victoria Bonjour now as a head
of community and communications our
music is by the great gunnarolla Hank we
are now going to go record our extra
podcast for patreon this weekend Ryan's
which you can find out more about over
at patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
thanks again for listening and as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]